the Midwest and the Northeast are
finally getting some relief from a
punishing week-long heatwave in
Washington DC temperatures could even
sink into the 60s burr
there's a very different story in the
West parts of Southern California Nevada
and Arizona are under excessive heat
warnings forecasters say the heat could
be unprecedented with temperatures
expected to hit triple digits
fire crews battling several wildfires in
the state say that could make their task
even harder Carter Evans is in Manhattan
Beach which is under an excessive heat
warning Carter good morning good morning
coming up a little bit later today
temperatures are expected to reach the
80s and even the 90s here on the beach
and cooling off in the ocean may not be
such a good option that's because the
remnants of hurricane Fabio are creating
some serious rip tides and that's
creating a perfect storm of miserable
weather as Southern Californians look
for heat relief at the beach or in
fountains and splash pads they're
getting ready for what could be a record
shattering weekend fine shade definitely
and then drink as much water as you can
that's the biggest thing at least 11
areas in Southern California are
expected to have temperatures climbed
past their own record heat by double
digits this is historical this is
absolutely historical Evelyn Taft is a
meteorologist at CBS in Los Angeles some
of the records that we're expecting our
breaking records by a good 10 degrees
because we have this kind of heat and
offshore conditions and say you have a
little bit of dry lightning that comes
in that's it that's a recipe for a fire
right there fires are still breaking out
across California there are now 60 large
fires burning across the United States
in Colorado more than 130 homes have
been destroyed and more than 2,000
people evacuated back in California
authorities at Huntington Beach say
those headed to the ocean to escape the
heat need to be on the lookout for
dangerous conditions combined the crowds
coming out the dynamic environment the
swell picking up we're expecting to be
very busy the next few days
he's talking about the swell picking up
there the National Weather Service says
it could reach 10 feet on beaches like
this today that is great for surfers not
so much for everyone else lifeguards are
recommending if you're not an advanced
swimmer despite the heat you should stay
out of the water thanks Gianna hopefully
residents will be heating those warnings
Carter thank you so much